[Applause]
ending a long-running tv series is never
easy and
many otherwise great shows have been
scuppered by an uneven finale
sometimes however everything comes
together perfectly leaving fans more
than satisfied
here are some tv shows that manage to
stick the landing
the americans is about a family of
soviet deep cover agents living in the
suburbs of washington dc
obviously then things were never going
to turn out well over the course of the
series the secret identities of philip
and elizabeth jennings are unknown to
everyone but each other
and later their american daughter paige
their fbi agent neighbor stan beeman
however has his suspicions
and in the series finale start they're
finally proven true
although the jennings managed to flee to
russia stan does get a chance to
confront them at gunpoint in a tense
standoff
one that could easily have been the end
of the road for the jennings family
all this time
i would have done anything for you phil
hanging over all this of course
is the bittersweet knowledge that the
cold war is coming to an end
the title of the episode itself refers
to an actual strategic
arms treaty between the united states
and the soviet union
one of the most important diplomatic
moments of the late cold war
the episode received widespread acclaim
with particular focus being given to the
dramatic
and nail-biting confrontation between
stan and the jennings family
practically every line in the scene was
masterfully written and performed making
it perhaps the most memorable moment in
a series packed full of them
broad city is a sitcom about the real
life friendship between comedians ilana
glaser and abby jacobson
two young women struggling to make it in
new york city the whole show is bizarre
and wonderful and the finale named after
the show itself
is one of its most special episodes in
the finale abby is preparing to move to
boulder colorado for a new job
opportunity
she and alana trek around the city in
search of one last bodega breakfast
sandwich before the lunch menu goes up
at 11am
a whole bunch of hilarity ensues mostly
involving a perfectly functioning toilet
they find on the street
and a daylight robbery in the shadow of
the brooklyn bridge
and yeah it's all a little weird but
that's broad city for you
finally ilana and abby throw one last
party in part ways for good but
promise to stay in touch regularly over
the phone this finale simultaneously
wraps up the story neatly and
perfectly captures the zany heartwarming
energy that made broad city one of the
best shows of the decade
by the time you reach the end part of
you wants to just flip back to season 1
and start it all over again which is
exactly the mark of a truly great finale
the appropriately named office episode
finale pivots around angela martin's
marriage to salesman turned manager
dwight schrute also features a seriously
meta team
q a panel about well the office
do you find that your life feels
pointless now that nobody's actually
filming you anymore
yes in the iconic show's final moments
the main cast gathers in the office to
spend a final evening together
on paper it's overstuffed even for a
double episode but after nine seasons
it honestly feels like it's not enough
you want every moment to drag on a
little longer because the thought of
your time at dunder mifflin scranton
coming to an end
is well a little bit heartbreaking and
so what if it's a little sappy
finale is a pitch perfect ending for an
outrageous comedy that found its heart
and then some along the way
in terms of highlights everyone loves
the michael scott appearance
but the ending is arguably the best
moment of all
perhaps that's the show's greatest
accomplishment taking a cast of
potentially boring background characters
and bringing them to life while
lampooning the mundanity of 9-5 work
everyone is a bit of a star in the end
and everyone gets just enough of a happy
ending to keep the audience happy too
ultimately the finale more than makes up
for the show's final two questionable
seasons and helps make
the office one of the most rewatchable
series of all time
the west wing stumbled a bit after
creator and head writer aaron sorkin
departed the show following its fourth
season
however its seventh and final season is
undoubtedly one of the west wing's
strongest
the season focuses largely on president
bartlett's final months as president
and the election between democrat matt
santos and republican arne vinnick
and even features a live presidential
debate between the two candidates that
felt
bizarrely authentic the final episode
tomorrow mostly deals with santos's
victory and upcoming inauguration
the aftermath of leo mcgarry's
unexpected passing and the bartlett
administration's fond memories of the
past eight years in office tomorrow
wasn't just a nostalgia fest though
and its most powerful moment comes
during the episode's final scene
what are you thinking about
tomorrow this vision of earnestness and
optimism in politics feels like
everything the west wing had been
building towards and
seems even more necessary today than it
did 15 years ago
anyone who's seen it will tell you that
fleabags should never have a third
season
that's not to say the show wasn't great
of course anything but
the final episode of season 2 however
wrapped things up so perfectly that
nothing
more needs to be said in case you're
unaware fleabag follows star and creator
phoebe waller bridge through her
escapades as a confused free-spirited
and nameless woman
in london the final episode is a pitch
perfect farewell to the show
ultimately it ends with a breakup flea
bag and the priest decide that despite
their love for each other their
relationship just won't work out the
episode ends with a knowing wink to the
show's fourth wall breaking format
it's an achingly beautiful ending with
just the right dash of ambiguity
will fleabag return to her old
self-destructive ways or will she grow
up at last and move forward
you can't know for sure but you can
always hope for the latter
at 12 episodes fleabag is so short that
it almost qualifies as a miniseries but
it uses every minute of scream time to
devastating effect
and effortlessly leaves its bizarre
wonderful mark on tv
history the wire is the story of a
society in crisis
one in which little acts of
opportunistic selfishness incentivize
yet more cheating a cycle that
ultimately leads to an endless churning
wheel of systemic corruption and despair
the show's final episode 30 is one of
change
mayor carcadi leaves for the governor's
mansion valchek replaces daniels as
commissioner
mcnulty is fired for insubordination and
replaced as the resident problematic cop
by a disillusioned keema gregg's
meanwhile bubbles gets clean while dukie
gets hooked
omar is dead and michael lee takes up
his mantle marlow walks free but loses
his empire
while slim charles and the new day co-op
assume the reigns of power on the
streets
but these changes are deceptive as the
wire comes to an end the wheel continues
to turn and baltimore's vicious cycle of
crime and anger has failed to be broken
new players may have stepped up to
assume control but you don't need to see
what happens to them
because you've spent the last five
seasons learning that it hardly even
matters
in the end the garbage rolls downhill
and the neglected poor suffer the real
consequences
it's a tale as old as time but one that
has rarely been so
powerfully tragically and unforgettably
told who said only live-action shows can
have mighty endings
the iconic sci-fi series futurama
follows philip j frye
a down on his luck pizza delivery driver
who's cryogenically frozen by mistake
just before new year's day 2000.
he wakes up a millennium later in new
new york a city now dominated by flying
cars robots
mutants and aliens ferrei finds work
with the delivery crew of planet express
which takes him across the galaxy on a
series of bizarre adventures
more than anything else futurama is
crass clever and genuinely hilarious
honey we love you sure baby i knew it
thing is futurama also had the ability
to slip around your defenses and
actually make you feel something
fans still reference the episode's
jurassic park and the luck of the
frirish with reverence and
awe and its finale might have been the
show's crowning achievement in meanwhile
fry's misuse of a time reverting button
designed by professor farnsworth results
in the world being frozen
except for himself and leela this allows
the two to grow old
together and alone in the end a
malfunction results in
all the events of the entire show thus
far being reset
as fry and leela agreed to go around one
more time
when the finale first aired comedy
central aired the pilot episode again
immediately after which begs the
question did futurama
even end it's been repeatedly noted by
fans and critics alike that mash lasted
far longer than the actual korean war
nonetheless it still felt hard to say
goodbye when the 11 season ratings
behemoth finally bid ado
in 1983. the final episode appropriately
entitled goodbye farewell and
amen depicts the final days of the
korean war through the eyes of its main
cast
in the end a ceasefire is declared and
the group throws a final party
the next day after klinger and soon
lee's marriage everyone says their final
goodbyes and departs for home
the episode was nominated for a whole
heap of emmys and golden globes but more
importantly it had the approval of the
masses too
bringing in a jaw-dropping 121.6 million
viewers beating out that year's super
bowl
goodbye farewell and amen remains one of
the most watched broadcasts in the
history of television
many shows are remembered more for their
finales than for anything else but
that's usually because
things have gone very wrong indeed not
so for six feet under however
which follows the fisher family and
their los angeles funeral home in the
tumultuous years after the death of the
family patriarch
the show itself was acclaimed for its
writing and acting throughout its run
but the finale is most fondly remembered
as one of the finest in television
history
the final episode everyone's waiting
bucks series tradition by
opening with a birth rather than a death
brenda and the late nate's daughter
willa is eight weeks premature and the
doctor tells her all they can do is hope
for the best
after checking in with all the surviving
characters the episode's final sequence
flashes forward to the deaths of the
entire main cast as claire
drives away from her family home to
begin a new life in new york
it's a beautiful chilling montage that
was totally unexpected when the episode
first aired
in hindsight though it feels like the
only satisfying way to end such a
macabre and groundbreaking show
it seems fitting that the show that came
closest to true perfection would be the
one to best stick its landing
it's also worth noting that few people
really knew how breaking bad was going
to end
that a show could keep such a passionate
fan base guessing right up until the
last moments is a testament to the
impeccable vision of showrunner vince
gilligan
probably an even bigger question than
how walter white's story would end was
what kind of catharsis if any he'd be
permitted
after all walt was both the show's main
character and its most soulless villain
in the end though he got exactly what he
wanted a chance to see his family one
last time
a last minute rescue for jesse vengeance
for the death of hank and one last
moment with his true love
a meth lab having been wounded in a
gunfight moments earlier walt collapses
onto the floor of the lab as the police
close in
undone by his own machinations but
satisfied with how he went out
it's more or less the perfect ending and
few shows have managed to match it since
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one